battlefield 5 slums completely for
tonight get some new very important
update keep watching to find out what it
is NASA gets a furry what and a once
again youtubers are crying about how
hard their life is booboo I'm poppy
Harlow and you're watching
our first story comes from battlefield
fight an analyst's predicts that EAS
battlefield 5 will be a serious
disappointment pre-orders like Call of
Duty buy more than 85% damn I know you
feel you feel it too don't you anyone
but EA America's fake most hated company
ah couldn't this please happen to anyone
else now I'm just poppy Harlow I'm not
supposed to give my own opinion or
speculation on this show but I think ok
I think I might having a clue of why the
battlefield 5 pre-orders are doing so
poorly but I think it might have
something to do with the battlefield 5
trailer completely flopping getting four
hundred and sixty thousand dislikes as
opposed to three hundred thirty four
thousand likes making it the worst
reveal trailer in their history and it
seemed to focus more on pushing some
form of social justice agenda as opposed
to just focusing on making it the
coolest trailer they could make you see
this that's a girl with that bionic arm
that's right they exist in World War two
and if you don't think so then you're
just uneducated
oh you think I'm joking no that's what
ei actually responded and said accept it
or don't buy the game the chief design
officer of battlefield Pathak Sutherland
said we felt like in today's world I
have a 13 year old daughter that when
the trailer came out and she saw all the
flak
she asked me dad why is this happening
she plays fortnight and says I can be a
girl in fortnight why are people so
upset about this and certainly responded
with did we play the sims in this house
or battlefield I'm just kidding that's
not what he said what he said was as a
parent how the heck am I gonna respond
to this and I just said you know what
you're right this is not okay then going
on to say these people who are
uneducated they don't understand that
this is a possible scenario
hey guys you remember that plausible
scenario where the
the way the girl with the bionic arm in
World War 2 just made everyone look
completely it like fools I had no idea
what they were doing remember her
remember that that's a plausible
scenario everyone knows that are you
uneducated or something like that ya
dingus then finally put Patrick
Sutherland said we don't take any flack
we'd stand up for the cost because I
think those people who don't understand
it well you have two choices either
accept it or don't buy the game I'm fine
with either or it's just not okay
what is this electronic art chief design
officer is leaving what just too much
before the launch of the new installment
of the biggest franchises pot
battlefield
Patrick Sutherland has been with EA for
nearly 20 years earlier this month crow
and said free order sales of battlefield
5 had been weak this is really strange
you know I shouldn't be putting pieces
together but I think I understand what
happened here this response to me it
sounds like someone that just doesn't
care it's someone that doesn't want to
take criticism or at least not trying to
understand what the criticism is and
instead you're drawing the line in the
sand between your consumers and what
your ideology is and this is the problem
that you face when you push social
politics into video game speakers like
any politics is all about making your
opponent seem like a villain so you're
basically making your consumers the
villain here and he's saying well if you
don't like what we're trying to do here
you're uneducated don't buy the game and
but instead of trying to understand what
the actual criticism he's making the
criticism seem like oh you're just an
educator or you're just a sexist or all
you don't want to see women in video
games huh is that the problem when
really that's not the problem at all
Patrick is not wrong for saying that
today's gaming is gender diverse or he's
not wrong for looking after the
interests of his daughter in video games
if the option was just for females to be
a playable character in battlefield 5 no
one would care but this trailer showed
so clearly that you care more about
pushing this agenda than making her a
cool trailer that's a problem it's a
statement this trailer it's basically a
hey huh what do you think about this
huh what's your opinion about this huh
look what we did that's why people don't
like it and instead of trying to
acknowledge that and trying to
understand that he says that everyone
else is just uneducated so it's no
surprise really that he was let go after
this I don't really want to celebrate
people losing their job or whatever
especially working so long but maybe
this would have been for the better I
understand that it's a good intention
just really bad execution then the
cluster F if you haven't followed the
marketing for battlefield 5 it gets
worse from here if you K for some reason
they decided to hire Trevor Noah to
market by to fill five Trevor Noah
of course which everyone knows as a
battlefield veteran everybody I don't
know about you guys but whatever Trevor
Noah opened his mouth I just cannot stop
laughing he's just too funny welcome
everyone to the battlefield 5 live
reveal I'm your host for this evening
Trevor Noah and I'm so excited to be
here introducing this new edition of
battlefield which for some reason
everyone has really assumed this
battlefield 5 I mean and not battlefield
V could be V why not V it stands for a
vagina see I don't even need writers to
do the work for me I'm way back these is
no offense to Trevor if people like them
great but there's clearly so fake and
it's so painfully transparent during
this reveal that they did their remarks
he makes are so cringy co-op is back and
that's one of my favorite aspects of
battlefield one battlefield one oh
favorite aspects of battlefield 1 first
and foremost Trevor Noah first and
foremost I'm a gamer favorite aspects of
battlefield one I'm a gamer
first and foremost everybody expect
anyone to believe this yikes
ok Wow the car the thing the man the boo
you saw the thing man uh-huh I hope they
got insurance that was insane do you see
that how many millions do they spend on
this look at it they built this whole
set right they hired Trevor Noah
how much do you think this cause
I feel bad because clearly there's so
many bad decisions being made by a
minority of people I'm sure there's
plenty of really talented people working
on this game dice is a very good student
I think they made some amazing games and
I'm really a big fan oh but it seems
like you got the wrong people making the
wrong decisions and I I don't know I
feel bad for all the other people
working on because there's probably a
massive team on it it's done so far that
even the fans for battlefield 5 themself
is our memeing the whole thing mess up
the reveal tell people not to buy the
game if they don't like it people don't
buy the game what people don't buy the
game big shocker everyone thanks did you
completely eff up the marketing for this
game EA
yes fans what did it cost everything
that's it for there that next news
here's the sentence I never thought I
would say a furry got accepted into NASA
that's right
2018 everybody what a time to be alive
on Twitter and now Miege tweeted
everyone shut the F up I got accepted
for a NASA internship then Homer Hickam
or hi Kim I don't know tweeted back
saying language then snow me feeling
back
suck my dick and balls I'm working at
NASA
Homer responded with I am on the
National Space Council that oversees
NASA bum bum bum ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
butter butter
what's this nectar Lucis job after
vulgar tea oh my god this is just too
funny it's too good
how did this happen how do you not look
up who you're tweeting at if you tell
someone to suck your dick and balls like
I'm the most irresponsible person I know
I even I would do that a simple Google
search and here you would know that
Homer Hickam is a former NASA engineer
who trained the first Japanese astronaut
Jesus Christ
so basically Homer wasn't the one
responsible for Naomi losing her
internship he made a response to this
saying he wasn't offended by the word he
was actually looking after
now me to make sure that this wouldn't
get her in trouble and the fact was that
actually all the people that kept hating
on Homer for tweeting this actually are
the ones that brought it to NASA's
attention because they used the hashtag
NASA hashtag or whatever and the ones
that actually were responsible for the
recruit recruitment of this individual
saw it and then decided well we can't
let this person come on board which is
pretty understandable I'm not for anyone
losing their job or internship or
whatever I hope that this person do
actually get another chance but it's
really funny nevertheless just from the
sense of haha screw you guys self
justice instant self justice it's funny
I think most people can agree on that
next news fortnight's gets an update you
can now press down to thank the bus
driver before jumping in for tonight we
did it guys we did it
our memes made an influence I'm so proud
we chill this in a meme review in June
talking about the bus driver meme
immediately you guys started memeing it
on the PewDiePie's subreddit the same
day it came out people started tweeting
there should be an option where you can
thank the bus driver and they listen
so now thanks to thanks to the power of
memes we made a positive impact in the
world and you can now thank the bus
driver in fortnight I never been this
pride proud give yourself a pat on the
back everybody we did it for tonight has
officially become the best reality I'm
sorry pub gene you had your chance
next knows you tubers are feeling the
Bern Oh what are they complaining about
now huh I don't want to hear this
Swedish millionaire complain again
alright the reason I'm bringing this up
is because it got a lot of mainstream
media attention that youtubers feeling
fatigued or worked out it was covered by
The Guardian and the telegraphed and
polygon I actually didn't hate that
article how about that they also
mentioned my video in it I made a video
again
think a month ago or something like that
where I talked about I try to give some
insight on what it's like to be a use of
creator and I did this mainly because I
think a lot of people think that just
because you get money and fame all your
other problems will go away and I try to
get some insight to explain why that
isn't necessarily the case I know it's
really tired and overhearing me talking
about this but I think this video
probably played a big impact on this
getting more attention which I'm really
glad about i luckily don't feel burnout
i feel better than i ever done on
youtube and this is all really thanks to
me making better decisions I think and
also you guys it's so easy to get caught
up with the numbers and this is what
these articles are talking about because
you can take a break I it'll be a
problem and I feel bad seeing a lot of
my friends suffer from this as well
feeling burned out feeling really worn
down because of it and I want that's why
I made that video to hopefully get give
people inside because I think the more
people understand each other the world
will be a better place that's right
that's all I care about I just want
people to be happy trust me that's my
number one priority it's much like on
this video say it will get more views
that would help me out a lot thank you
very much for watching make sure to hit
sponsor it so become a sponsor so you
can see that and that's it for me for
now thank you guys so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]